is the start of this team I think this
is uh it feels like like 2012 all over
again and we'll talk about that game you
can go back and figure it out but this
was so similar and I mean it was not a
guy on that sidelines in that we were
connected to that thought we weren't
gonna win that football game and all the
way till we didn't Pete Carroll talking
about the outcome of Sunday's game at
Green Bay he said it felt like 2012 all
over again during the 2018 season Peter
I spoke to Russell Wilson after they
beat the Lions 28 to 14 on the road and
we started to take the Seahawks
seriously at a time when many thought
they were gonna have a down year and
they were rebuilding Wilson told me then
it feels like 2012 so it's always gonna
feel like 2012 until the year they win
the Superbowl because that's what 2013
brought and I feel like they're not far
away and there were some comments
yesterday from Russell Wilson where he
is determined to get back and win it I
just don't know what more they need to
get there Wilson acknowledged they need
some other pieces and obviously the
defense isn't what it was back when they
were a Super Bowl team but to have
Russell Wilson playing at a high level
making things happen when nothing is
there that's something that few teams
have and that's something that makes it
easier to build around Mike I think that
the most important piece they need went
up walked up to John Schneider's office
at the close of business yesterday in
Renton Washington and thanked him for
the experience a of trading for him and
B the experience being able to play for
the Seahawks and that's Jadeveon Clowney
the the Seahawks whether it's cloudy I
mean cloudy could get stupid money
somewhere I'm not sure if he will but he
could and I don't think Schneider wants
to pay him stupid money
I think Schneider would like to convince
him this is a place where you're gonna
win a championship and yeah you could go
you can go probably make more money
elsewhere but I think this is going to
be in my opinion I think John Schneider
his moves
in 2019 he is my executive of the year
and to repeat that I think he's got to
convince clowny to come in for a
contract that the team's gonna be able
to live with in 2020 a Peter you spoke
earlier about analytics pointing to the
scarcity of highly competent defensive
backs as being more valuable making them
more valuable because there are more
pass rushers out there but there are a
few who have the potential when the
planets align perfectly to be as
disruptive as Jadeveon Clowney can be
the problem is it's like seeing Bigfoot
right it doesn't happen very often when
it happens it's magical and that's
really the question of team has to ask
he had three sacks he missed five games
but the performance he put on the night
they beat the 49ers was a rare thing to
behold how much do you pay for that and
it's almost as if the Seahawks need to
see what someone else would pay for it
before they make a decision and even
though they can't use the franchise tag
they could use the transition tag on
Jadeveon Clowney giving them a right to
match so they could see you use a
transition tag he's guaranteed to make
very good money and he has the right to
see what's out there and if someone
wants to put together an offer if the
seahawks look at and say yeah you know
what we need him enough we're gonna pay
that so be it that may be how this one
plays out yeah and I think the other
thing you need to do Mike you mention it
you may also need to sculpt your
contract sort of more than many
contracts that you do you may need to do
your contract in a way that a lot of the
money is going to be on the come and
that you have it you have it be an
incentive Laden contract so that for
instance he would make what the top free
agents would make at that position if he
plays 16 games and gets 15 sacks or
whatever whatever Escalade or whatever
incentives are built in there and you
can also obviously use that contract and
compare it to some of the other
contracts I think John Schneider has
been really imaginative on some of the
deals that he's done
in my opinion he's gonna have to get
imaginative to keep Jadeveon Clowney
from going somewhere else and the key
for clowny is this if you're gonna do
that if you're gonna have an incentive
Laden deal do a one-year contract not a
three-year deal get back to the market
if you have that big year in 2020 so you
can get that reward that long-term
contract he never got with the value
that he should have gotten as the first
overall pick in the draft because he
ended the league three years after the
NFL cut back dramatically on what guys
make when they are taken number one
overall I feel bad for him he's never
gotten that big money multi-year deal
Peter he's a great player but injuries
have been a major factor well I don't
feel bad for him because if he was a
great player who wasn't injured a lot
and who also performed more consistently
in Houston than he did then he would
have gotten that contract and so I don't
I don't feel bad for him if he's great
he'll get his money
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports